y jean jaurés un nuevo intento hacia la
gobernabilidad el presidente peruano
pedro castillo posesión de este martes a
su tercer gabinete ministerial
conformado por nueve nuevos ministros un
primer ministro y nueve más que fueron
ratificados en sus cargos un cambio
obligatorio tras conocerse la dimisión
de la primera ministra mirtha vásquez y
de otros funcionarios incluyendo al
ministro del interior- avelino guillén
saludó al actual gabinete presidido por
héctor valer desde el gobierno
ratificamos el compromiso de trabajar
por el perú revisando las necesidades de
todos los peruanos y las grandes
reformas que consolidarán el bienestar
nacional
en el palacio de gobierno héctor valer
juramento como nuevo presidente del
consejo de ministros
de 62 años y abogado de profesión valer
fue elegido como congresista por el
partido de derecha renovación popular
que dejó un tiempo después para ser
parte de la bancada perú democrático que
respalda el presidente por su parte
oscar graham ex director general del
mercado financiero del ministerio de
economía y finanzas pasará a encabezar
lo mientras que el constitucionalista
césar landa será el nuevo ministro de
exteriores
pero no gabinete no está exento de
polémica el nombramiento de alfonso
chávarry como nuevo ministro del
interior ha desatado críticas de varios
sectores políticos chávarri ex oficial
de la región de cajamarca quien se había
desempeñado como director general de
seguridad ciudadana tiene una sentencia
por abuso de autoridad y un proceso por
tráfico ilícito de drogas en medio de
dudas por sus nuevos nombramientos
casillo deberá sortear un complejo
panorama con un primer reto obtener el
voto de confianza del parlamento
una difícil tarea que se le suma a los
pendientes del mandatario que deberá
hacerle frente a la caída de su
popularidad al mismo tiempo en que se
enfrenta a múltiples cuestionamientos
sobre su legitimidad como presidente